our responsibility is to always inspire
and try to take some of the life lessons
that we have learned and share those
with the next generation so that they
can start their journey with a leg of
the Mambo Sports Academy says they will
honor Kobe Bryant's memory by dropping
the word mamba from its name confusing
right well here's what went down back in
2018 Kobe partnered up with the sports
Academy a youth sports training
organization which led to the name
change
Mamba Sports Academy it's a place for
kids to reach their full potential yeah
it's also a place for families to come
in trust that this is a facility where
they can they can they can they can
trust that their kids are in the best
care that's where we try to create Kobe
was super involved this facility is
unbelievable how much will you be here
because you're gonna have to take the
helicopter to game yeah yeah but I come
I come in actually I come in I hang out
my girls team will come out here and
play in tournaments and have practice
this year and train here so I'll be out
here pretty often in fact he was
traveling to the facility in Thousand
Oaks with his daughter Gianna and seven
others when their helicopter crashed in
January now the sports Academy's founder
and CEO Chad Faulkner says the company
will make some big changes as a tribute
to the late NBA star in a statement
posted to their Twitter account on
Tuesday Faulkner explained quote with
respect for an unparalleled legacy the
Academy will retire the Mamba in the
Mamba Sports Academy name to raise it to
the rafters where it belongs
in a follow-up tweet Sports Academy
added that the decision was not one we
came to lightly or on our own adding it
was a mutual agreement made in
accordance with the wishes of his estate
the tweet concluded thinking fans for
respecting that decision in these
turbulent times while the Mamba has been
dropped from the Sports Academy Kobe's
wife Vanessa Bryant has some big plans
for her late husband's foundation in
February she announced the Mamba Sports
Foundation will now be known as the
Mamba and mamacita sports foundation to
equally honor both Kobe and Gianna she
announced the news on Instagram writing
our
remains the same and stronger than ever
to provide opportunities to young people
through sports we hope to empower young
athletes in a world they left us all to
help shape ET recently spoke to fellow
basketball great Magic Johnson who
shared an update on how vanessa and
their three girls
Natalya Bianca and Capri are doing and I
think Kobe would have wanted that right
for them to go on live a great life and
just have enjoy yourself and Vanessa's
the reason for that and I think she's
got a great village around or people
around her to give her that support part
of that support system vanessa is close
friend
Lala Anthony who told ET she couldn't be
more proud of her I talked to her every
single day and just you know continue to
pray for her and stay positive for her
she I tell every day she's the strongest
woman I know and I'm really really proud
of just how she's handling everything
and just want to continue to be there
you know as much as I can for her as a
friend she's just an amazing and amazing
human being just just amazing